[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nicolas et pimprenelle
sont allés faire une grande promenade à
la campagne au j'espère qu'ils m'ont
rapporté dupont voyant nounours tu es
trop gourmand qui ne pense qu'à manger
vous trouvez pas trop vous faites de la
pub et bien j'étais sans victoire c'est
chair et en os ou de cheveux beaucoup
incorrigible nounours boussois up
redonne 11 3 tu sais on est à la
campagne et on a bien joué et on t'a
apporté quelque chose
quelque chose qui va te faire plaisir
qu'aujourd'hui au ce sont deux fleurs
matteau nicolas choisir mes mots ce
qu'est le mien nous les petits le gros
bouquet de boue je suis sûr qu'ils
centre bourg tout ce qui se dit fort
d'écolo au bonheur des mois où je suis
plots de béton leur mouvement
aujourd'hui partout ça craque chapitre
euros non atteints de notre boîte l'été
oui sans doute encore celui-là est bon
hugo le bouquet de petits garnements et
de petit ego de me faire de blagues
pareilles je n'aime pas ça du tout où ce
n'est pas du tout ce genre à long ou 10
pouces offert une bague arrêt à froid
ma pauvre sera remis lors si tu voyais
au sort de phase iib manon 7 est pour
rien qu'elle nourrit tient du celle-là
elle sommes vraiment bon oui on dirait
une belle sens pour toi et pour le petit
marchand de sable
oui vous êtes de gentil petit chenapan
mais je vous aime bien combes
merci les ans on vous ne ferez plus de
blattes normal heart is en dort mu 2
pagny nounours chuta le tome
bonne nuit nicolas n'en reviens pas
preneur
[Musique]
à te voilà mon gros nounours 10 dont ils
t'ont fait une bonne blague ce soir nos
deux petits amis nicolas et pimprenelle
hausse est vrai patron je les aime bien
tout de même regard du l'épeule flore
qu'ils m'ont offert russe pu rue lors
pas fort elles sentent bon allons en
route nounours bonne nuit les enfants à
demain fait doux rêve
faute de douloureux goût adopo
[Musique]